das gemacht wird sie gern gemacht doch
geholfen und dabei
bis ums leben gekommen
katharina ist gestorben wie es gelebt
hatte
[Musik]
als feuerwehrfrau deutschen durch und
natürlich bin ich gewohnt stolz auf
katharina
katharina maria wurde nur 19 jahre alt
sie war mitglied der freiwilligen
feuerwehr bei ihrem einsatz mitte juli
letzten jahres in der flut an der ahr
kamen sie ums leben
ihre eltern frauke und udo trauern um
ihr einziges kind katharina war von
klein auf weiter feuerwehr gemeinsam mit
ihrem vater in ihrem heimatdorf in der
eifel erst bei der jugendfeuerwehr mit
16 wechselte sie zu den großen
der einsatz in dem sie starb fand auf
dem campingplatz stahlhütte stadt in
dorsten an der oberen
katharinas vater ist dabei erfährt das
feuerwehrauto uns wieder hingefahren
sind noch alle witzigen den vater zu
spielen macht hat man keinen wohnwagen
retten
das hat so
viele menschen noch da drin war oder
husten pädagogische
einige menschen können rechtzeitig
fliehen andere bleiben in ihren
wohnwagen und mobilheimen während das
wasser der aa gefährlich schnell steigt
katharina und das feuerwehr team gehen
auf den platz um die leute zu warnen und
geraten plötzlich selbst in gefahr
sie sind von dem was überrollt worden
also ich habe von kameraden gehört die
da vor ort waren die sagten wir sind
noch bis zum knie wasser rein wollen und
auch menschen rausholen und als wir uns
umgedreht haben ist das wie eine welle
auf uns zu gekommen dass dieses projekt
noch selber retten konnten sonst wären
sie mit weggespült wurde auch traktoren
müssen zurücksetzen sie drohen im wasser
abzutreiben katharina wird von der flut
eingeschlossen sie ist in einem
mobilheim bei einer bettlägerigen frau
geblieben wartet dort auf unterstützung
doch niemand kommt mehr durch
hab ich nur noch dagestanden und
gewartet
und du hast versucht sie zu retten und
ja ich bin noch mal mit meinem neffen
so ein stück in die fluten reihe nach
schon das wasser schon bis hier und
heute ecke kamen
aber die strömung dann so stark dass wir
nicht weitergehen konnten
nur aus der luft sind die
eingeschlossenen noch zu erreichen vom
nahen nürburgring kommt ein hubschrauber
und erkundet das gelände in einem
mobilheim sieht die besatzung ein
lebenszeichen beim ersten überflug wir
ankamen konnten wir dort sehen dass der
taschenlampe städten wir wussten zu dem
zeitpunkt nicht dass katharina dort war
an anderer stelle entdeckt der
hubschrauber einen feuerwehrmann und
mehrere camper auf einem dach doch der
hubschrauber hat keine seilwinde in
einem waghalsigen manöver gelingt es den
menschen feuerwehr gurte anzulegen und
sie anfang leinen herauszuziehen wir
haben die leute daran mit dem
hubschrauber und mit manneskraft im
endeffekt quer durchs wasser zum anderen
ufer gezogen das war natürlich sehr
schwierig da hatten die drei punkt
unterwegs war und war also schon sehr
riskant auch für die die leute fünf
personen und den feuerwehrmann können
sie so retten danach suchen sie weiter
nach katharina dann kam der notarzt noch
mal zu mir und sagte zu hören war
fliegen aber ja sie sehen nur geflogen
habe nichts mehr beim zweiten überflug
noch wasser war stand kein campingwagen
ja die waren mal alles schon
zusammengeschoben abgetrieben
das ist alles versucht und ich möchte
den leuten die da waren danken
nürnberg ihr bestes gegeben habe ja es
war nichts mehr zu machen
katharina die frau die sie retten wollte
und fünf weitere kämpfer werden von der
flut weggerissen
es dauert drei tage bis die junge
feuerwehrfrau gefunden wird ein stück
weiter flussabwärts
katharinas tod ist ein entsetzlicher
verlust auch für ihre kameraden und
kameradinnen von der feuerwehr die sie
von klein auf kannten sie zeigen höchste
anerkennung sie heute leben gelassen bei
ihrem liebsten wasser sieht was sie tun
wollten also sie überhaupt da für andere
menschen da sein helfen die frau war
bettlägerig die war krank so war sie bei
ihr weil die beete wahrscheinlich dann
alleine gewesen und so war katharina
auch jemand vorbei und ich denke mal das
war so dem moment wo man sagen kann ja
das kann einem helfen die trauer zu
verarbeiten
für mich jedenfalls
in der großen anteilnahme der feuerwehr
familie und ihre dorfgemeinschaft finden
katharinas eltern ein wenig halt für sie
ist wichtig dass ihre tochter in guter
erinnerung bleibt
katharina ist eigentlich so viel mehr
als nur die feuerwehrfrau gewesen also
sie war im karneval aktiv
unheimlich selbstbewusst
und hilfsbereit sie war blutspender und
organspende und streitschlichter in der
schule das war alles ganz
wichtig danken all die katharina in
ihrer lehrzeit auch nur lächeln aufs
gesicht gezaubert haben
die das leben für katharina lebenswert
gemacht haben
katharina fehlt furchtbar zum andenken
an sie und die sechs anderen flutopfer
vom campingplatz haben überlebende einen
gedenkstein aufgestellt
direkt am ufer der aare in docs